it'd be interesting to ask your thoughts
about something which is um
autonomous weapon systems us has now
officially released a report
saying that they're open to uh not open
they're
engaging in in adding more and more
autonomy and artificial intelligence
into its weapon systems
because china is doing it so there's
these are the first steps
and then something that ai folks worry
about which is uh
a race an ai race
in the space of autonomous weapons that
can run away
uh too quickly is that something um
i don't know if in general if you have
thoughts about
weapon systems that make autonomous
decisions
at the small scale of just targeting
where to shoot
and the largest scale of military
strategy
of just get being given a mission of
destroy this particular target this
particular
say terrorist human being
and then figure out what is the right
bombing campaign on your own
to accomplish this task that minimizes
civilian death
and and then just loading that in and
letting the ai system automatically
decide that
uh what are your general thoughts about
it do you do you worry about it
because as the positive effects that
in the best version of that world you
kill fewer civilians you
kill hurt fewer of your own human beings
but at the negative side of that
you might lose the the thing we kind of
talked about which is the basic humanity
even in the individual soldier
of what is right and what is wrong and
not
making huge mistakes that hurt thousands
or millions of people
i guess what you're asking me is if they
could make a machine that could
do more surgical attacks on
enemy individuals would i be for it
yes i would be for it the problem is
if you've ever used machines of any kind
their initial design may not be there
there's unintended consequences there's
uh
there's ways in the the machine actually
behaves
that you realize there's bugs in this
thing
so do we not put protocols in place to
prevent
something from going too far outside the
boundaries of what we wanted to execute
you do but the question is uh
this is the first time in human history
you can create things
machines toaster microwave oven
that's smarter than you in this
particular task
i mean it's not yet there we are
learning a lot with military strategies
humans are actually really damn smart
it's very hard to do to improve on a
human
and so most actual drones that are
unmanned are still piloted by humans
it's very difficult to do every aspect
of war
but it's not a out of the realm of
possibility that
machines will start doing those things
better in certain certain things
a certain more precise targeting of the
enemy
the question is so what happens
when you start to rely on the machine to
do some of the task
is you get lazy you forget what it is
like
to do that task or more importantly you
lose the knowledge of the intricacies of
that task
and you forget the ways it can go wrong
so the protocols
may not be sufficient to constrain the
power
of the ways that things go wrong
especially when things are moving really
quickly
especially when the ethics of the two
sides aren't perfectly aligned
when people are some certain sides like
on the chinese side
may be more willing to take risks
for dangerous consequences than others
so what happened on the bioweapon side
is internationally maybe you can speak
to this more but
my sense what i was told there's a sense
globally that buy weapons are not going
to be used
they're unethical there's a sense like
we're not going to engage in this
and with ai currently china
and u.s said green light
all go ahead it's it's totally ethical
if if it can decrease the loss of human
life
why not my worry is
that uh it's much more it's
it's much easier to design weapons
that are effective
than design weapons who have the the
depth of ethics
and morals that humans do which i think
we don't as human beings don't
acknowledge enough
that even like the cold calculated
killing of others
like precise effective execution of a
mission
still has ethics in it at every level
you know what's right and what's wrong
and i don't know if that
i don't know if you take that away
you're not going to make huge mistakes
that you regret
is that something you don't
worry about i don't really worry about
it um
but as you design something like i said
you you put protocols in place and
and from what i am hearing you say or
trying to hear you say
there's be a point where our protocols
wouldn't be
wouldn't be sufficient to stop the
machine
from doing something that was unethical
i'm kind of worried that this is
something you don't worry about
because a lot of people i respect don't
worry about it and i don't know what to
do about that
a lot of generals don't worry about it a
lot of people who know
much more about war like you than me
don't worry about it and that worries me
well that's because you have a vision
into
the shortfalls of ai and i don't
i don't have a vision of the shortfalls
of ai i don't know enough about it
as far as i'm concerned you put a on off
switch somewhere you put a
a kill switch on a system
and if it starts going awry you hit the
kill switch and that's it
so if you know when you look at me and
say well there's
no possible way to put a kill switch
that would be 100 effective and here's
you draw those concerns to me and we
could talk through it and say okay
well here's where we should draw the
line yeah
i mean it's like again for the soviet
union chernobyl meltdown
there's always the ability i believe to
have a kill switch
the problem is uh the more power you
give to the machine
the more opportunity you give to the
to the human supervising that machine to
make a mistake and not
shut off the switch at the right time so
yes the solution i mean you're putting
the responsibility still in the human
hands and i think that's the correct
place to put it
there should be good protocols good
leadership good execution competency all
around
your protocols should consider the basic
failures of human nature the human
factor
of how things go wrong so there should
be multiple people supervising the
system all those things
but i am just very skeptical
of greater and greater power in the
machine that can create war
that can not lead to death yeah and
that's why like i said and like you just
said you have protocols in place that
that are a kill switch and if if you
think about the amount of
nuclear weapons that we've had on planet
earth for the past however many years
and there's been you know no
rogue element that said you know what
i'm gonna shoot this thing there's been
no
protocol that took place where all of a
sudden we said
oh no i mean there's been there's been
escalations
but the protocols worked have worked so
far
now that's a scary thing to think about
that we rely on these protocols to stop
some rogue element out there from
launching a
missile that could kill millions of
people and trigger
a global war so yeah the protocol should
be strict
okay
you